first of all how did you guys originally
come to this show like did you know what
your roles would develop into because
your characters are in a very different
place
than where they started
so did you have any clue that all of
this would be happening with them
well halia is on mute
hi there we go
um when i came onto the show
um eden was really meant to just be like
kind of the drama of school you know the
the popular girl who was just mean to
the new girl kinsey and whatnot and
caused some stuff with tyler
whatever and um
i
was blessed with the bigger opportunity
as when the season ended and they they
put eden as being this new demon and
then with season two it's just like blew
my mind to become a series regular i
mean biggest honor uh doctor can
experience um
and
she just became this like larger than
life entity that um was just incredibly
fun to play so i did not know that this
was where eden was going to go but i am
so glad and grateful that it is
i had a i had a bit of a different
experience when i first auditioned for
gabe
into the room to audition
uh they let me know right off the bat
that uh where gabe's character was
headed i think they had that planned a
little bit before
and uh
and i took that and i ran and i think i
was apparently one of the only people
that knew that wasn't a higher up or an
exec or producer or writer
that knew about my arc and
i told absolutely nobody
which proves two things uh one i can
keep a secret
and two
i'm an idiot because i just thought
everyone knew um
that's why i didn't mention it really so
i don't even get credit for the first
thing
was it hard to wait to get to that point
i mean the whole time you were playing
him
you know before he gets to be
in the big bad of the season
was it hard to were you just sort of
anxiously awaiting to get to that point
no i was i was enjoying it um it was
more about the journey and not the
destination for me throughout the season
because i knew eventually
you know season two would come around
and you know thank
meredith and carlton and all the the
rest of the producers and the writers so
much joe hill
um and just everyone i'm
i'm not gonna name everyone because i'm
gonna leave someone out and someone's
gonna get hurt but
um thanks to them i sort of knew um that
season two was going to be my time to to
play around and have fun with my
character
um and do all these evil wicked things
uh so season one
was really about the journey uh you know
and and and i don't think season two
would be as much fun if i didn't get to
build up that character and the the
suspense and and the thrill of the big
plot twist so i wasn't eagerly awaiting
my chance i was excited to set the
groundwork for um my opportunity to
really
go at it full
force well you knew that he eventually
would get there but did you know what
the full
story arc would be really for both of
your characters did you go into this
season knowing what the full journey for
the season would be
once you were prepared to you know be
playing the villains
yeah not at all personally no they um
they give us the scripts as we go
um
so we didn't really
get any information on the end of the
season until maybe episode five
filming episode five i would say barely
i don't even think we got episodes the
last few episodes until like the week
before
i was told some things in episode five
so that's like when i registered
yeah there were a lot of rumors and
things like that that was like high
school like drama stuff right there like
going up to somebody like did you hear
that this person this was
someone else being like that's not what
i heard i heard that sound like this to
that person and you go wait what yeah um
so it was a lot of it was a lot of rumor
mills you know people hearing different
things from different people and
everyone asking what was gonna happen at
the end of season two but we didn't know
anything until we actually got the
scripts yeah
how did you guys approach finding these
characters for yourselves because they
are a bit unusual
in the sense that you know they are
villains and we see
certain things come out of them at
different times but they're not always
one way so how did you
figure out how you wanted to play that
and how big you would go at any given
time
um it was really just i trusted the
moment and i through filming i really
learned to trust myself in certain ways
because i mean
a lot of this stuff i've never done
before in my life
um i think griffin has had similar
experiences where it was just like
it's not
it's not typical in your day-to-day to
do a lot of the things that we got to do
um in this season so just trusting the
moment and going into it being like i'm
gonna figure this out sometimes as as
we're going and because there's things
that you just can't prep for
um and just being present in the moment
of filming was a big thing that i
personally
um learned a lot to do in the second
season
if that answers the question yeah yeah
how about b.u griffin
um i'm so sorry please remind me we're
talking about um the experience of
shifting into that character right yeah
how you built the character and how you
decided because i mean you give some
great menacing face but sometimes he
also thank you
sometimes he also just seems like
you know a normal guy so how did you
gauge all of that
um it was definitely a challenge um i'm
not the most menacing person um
i'm a small man
um i am not a muscly man
um i think everything was working
against
my against me honestly
so it was a lot of fun for me to find
you know different ways to be menacing
and different ways to to to show
power or anger because i think when you
have someone that's
my size and my stature you know if i get
real mad like this you just want to
laugh you know it's not scary it's cute
um and
and so i had to find a way to you know
get rid of that and i think what i drew
from a lot was just you know watching
movies about psychopaths and
psychopathic tendencies and you know
christian bale and american psycho
um i'm not gonna say i drew a lot from
him for this character but
you know i love christian bale as an
actor and
something that he said about how he
prepared for
american psycho was he watched tom
cruise interviews
and i found this to be the funniest
thing but he's talked about how
he would watch tom cruise interviews and
he would be a bubbly person on the
outside very friendly very you know
approachable
but that he was just dead behind the
eyes and that that terrified christian
bale and
he said that he drew a lot from that for
american psycho and you know that kind
of got me thinking about other other
ways that i could draw from psychopathic
tendencies that are just you know
scary and very subtle ways you know the
dead behind the eyes was a big thing
even if you know there's a full grin
smile the eyes don't change
yeah
you know the eyes stay the same and and
that stuff's kind of that the small my
new details like that i think are what
really um helped me pull gabe together
you know
not you know not flinching confident
stature posture you know not doing this
thing that i do like right now where i
use my hands a lot bounce around while i
talk it's very just
straight deadpan not a lot of movement
and
i just found fun ways to
to to really sell the
psycho inside of gabe which was fun for
me
yeah because it's one of those things
where you can't just go research what
it's like to have a demon inside of you
so you have to just yeah out what that
could mean for yourself
yeah i think you know i sort of decided
on its equal parts psychopath and demon
um inside of him
actors often talk about being an
advocate for their character and having
to find something to love or identify
with about everybody they play
but when you play characters like this
do you even worry about that do you just
find a way to embrace who they are
instead of whether or not you like them
or what they're doing
uh
yeah
it's important to find those elements in
your character because the character
doesn't believe that they're wrong or
that they're doing anything wrong right
they they believe that they're doing the
right thing because that's that's their
goal or what they want
um and they're going to stop at nothing
and especially like i mean eden being a
baby demon she doesn't really have a
very like
very smart way of approaching things
always she's more um chaotic and and you
know unhinged
um
but she's
yeah she i just lost my train of thought
the first time that's happened in two
days
where was i
i'm just about you know embracing your
character and and how you
how you play somebody like that
yeah um i love the fact that eden is
just like very humorous and has a lot of
fun and i think i just i mean i i found
the
the humor in eden brought her back to
the
kind of the part that i could relate to
myself and kind of be like you know what
she's just living life this is just who
she is like she's just having a great
time and
whatever just let her run free like go
go be free demon girl go be free
yeah
if i may uh
i know that we i'm gonna try and keep
this brief uh because i hate when things
get cut short
um but i think for me it wasn't really
about uh you know accepting gabe for who
he was because at the end of the day he
is wrong you know he is a bad person
um so i wasn't really
necessarily concerned about being liked
or or anything like i kind of knew going
into the character that
gabe will not be liked and i can't wait
for the backlash because people don't
really know how to separate actors from
their characters so people are gonna
think i'm a real jerk for a while now
which i'm prepared for i'm stoked about
it
um that just means i did a good job
um but
you know i think the interesting thing
about villains is they have this
characteristic i think it's just how
driven they are that no matter how
unlikable they are
you root for them in some weird way
because without them the story wouldn't
move forward and you can see that in
shows like you um you know joe goldberg
is a terrible person who does terrible
things but he you can't help but root
for him you know he
i mean deep down he's doing it all
because
out of love and passion and you know he
wants his goal so badly
i think you know it's
it's more i think the right the the
writer's concern whether or not the
characters liked you know they can
decide entirely whether you know they're
going to structure it a certain way to
to give them any redeeming qualities and
you know i'm not sure if gabe has any of
those i guess we'll find out when people
give their opinions but
gabe is not a likable dude
that's nice of you um was not a fan of
his hair um
personally
but you know we'll see if gabe has any
redeeming qualities um i think i would
be the worst judge of that because
obviously
i'm a little too close to the situation
but you know like leah said uh our
characters do believe they're right and
i think in some part
you have to believe that as well uh to
really give the best performance
hello what was it like to find out about
the sequence trapped under the glass and
see what that looks like to get to do
that i mean that was just such a
fantastic moment personally i was so
excited for you dude when i read that i
was like this is gonna be so cool
yeah i i just i was over the moon um i
think a lot of it was you know after
episode five of season one of the table
cafeteria scene i just really like threw
myself into that and had a blast and
they were like okay she had a lot of fun
let's make her do even crazier things in
season two and they like definitely
didn't hold back on that
actually when we were in la after the
season one premiere we went to visit the
writer's room i was with jessie camacho
and patrice jones and we accidentally
walked into the writer's actual room
with all the things on the wall
of like ideas and jesse was like i saw
eden demon fun
that was all he saw we didn't see
anything else
but the glass thing um in season two was
just
incredible it was
it was so
it was so strange and such a like
because i i'm really learning about
myself as an actor and and i'm still
kind of like surprising myself which is
i think something that throughout a good
career you want to continue to surprise
yourself
and i
i
went for it um
i
kind of like i blew out my voice just
screaming just like those deep guttural
screams is something that i know
griffin's mentioned this that we as
humans don't typically get to do things
like this we don't like to like get to
unleash it's like a like one of those
like break like uh what was it called
the
the breaking
room the anger rooms you know but for an
actor
to be
you know put into this glass where it's
like scream as loud as you want hit the
glass as hard as you want i accidentally
actually punched the glass at one point
which
did not feel very good
um but it was just it was so much
fun to just unleash and i was very
excited for it
it's definitely a fantastic moment so
yeah thank you i appreciate you guys
talking to me about the season i had so
much fun with it thank you for thank you
so much so much it was a pleasure
talking to you you're both so fantastic
with these characters so thanks a lot
thank you that's very cool thanks so
much